[Music]
president Trump failing to fill the
arena after bragging that a million
people were trying to attend his rally
he had pushed his staff to hold it
despite concerns among some of his top
advisors that it was too soon to be back
in a rally like a rally setting like
this and what's left here is sort of an
embarrassing spectacle it is far lower
than the expectations at the White House
and the President himself put out they
expected this arena to be full you can
see behind me that there are seats that
are not filled for him all he cares
about is how it looks and boy oh boy it
looked embarrassing for him tonight okay
so you obviously see that media montage
criticizing the number of attendees at
the Trump rally last night well we have
someone who was there New York
Congressman Lee Zeldin joins the show
now to give us a little insight unto
what the mood was actually like so
congressman is that criticism my media
valid or was there a lot of energy on
the ground and are they wrong oh yeah
the energy was outstanding everybody who
was there they were excited to be there
there were people who were camped out
for days waiting for the opportunity to
get into the venue now as far as those
members of the media who were just
commenting if there were more people
there they'd be complaining that there
are too many they were going to they
showed this days in advance that they
were going to be complaining about the
amount of people who were there
regardless so there's that dynamic I'm
Oklahoma's deep into a reopening Joe
Biden is campaigning out of his basement
and they really don't want President
Trump to get back on the campaign trail
and president Trump's a type person
wants to get around America and be able
to do these rallies and understand
there's a huge stakes election coming up
in November and the president wants to
be out with with the people but the
energy inside of that arena was
absolutely fantastic of people bleeding
red white and blue loving our country
principled passionate they love their
president not just enough to be showing
up there but enough to be campaigning
hard to get him four more years in
office Congressman colleague of yours
see making bold claims let me explain
last night campaign manager Trump
campaign manager Brad Parks Cal tweeted
this about the crowd in attendance
saying radical protesters fueled by a
week of apoplectic media coverage excuse
me
interfered with Trump supporters at the
rally they even blocked access to the
metal detectors preventing people from
entering thanks to the thousands who
made it anyway well Alexandria custo
Cortez then gloating this actually you
just got rocked by teens on tick tock
who flooded the Trump campaign with fake
ticket reservations and tricked you into
believing a million people wanted you're
white supremacists open mic enough to
pack an arena drink ovid shoutout to
Zoomers y'all make me so proud
congressman your reaction well I think
AOC said the quiet part out loud you
know the fact that they you know metal
like this they don't have the
opportunity to register for a rally for
Joe Biden because now Joe Biden is
hanging out in his basement by the way
if Joe Biden was having a rally
yesterday in Tulsa Oklahoma for example
there would be barely anybody there at
all we saw a lot of the black lives
matter protesters and their activities
to prevent individuals from being able
to get into the venue and and again you
had people camping out there since
Wednesday so there are a few dynamics
that were at play I was sitting next to
one member of Congress who was having
constituents contacting him saying that
they had registered to come but they
didn't think that they'd be able to get
in if they came down but regardless of
that you know that you had just an
amazing energy inside of that room and
the folks who were there but you know
aoc bragging about them meddling like
that because they don't have better
things to do and we all tell you it you
know whole other say a dynamic is as I'm
coming here into the studio I got into
DC just a few hours ago and I'm seeing
all of these different businesses
boarded up and as that the substance of
what President Trump is talking about as
you look at Seattle and its effort to
fund the police and that reality that if
you call 911 because there's an intruder
in your house you don't want them to be
sending a social worker they don't want
to talk about the substance of what
President Trump is talking about from
the economy to national security
and and substantively there were a lot
of fantastic points that really really
highlight why President Trump is going
to end up getting reelected and I will
tell whether if you're out there and
you're a supporter of President Trump I
would say campaign like you're behind
regardless of what any poll ever shows
you know good bad or indifferent you
know we got to fight for it you can't
take anything for granted losing isn't
an option everything is at stake so just
get out after it forget about the polls
you have a president who's getting good
things done and he wants to get more
done for this country I mean congressmen
to your point it was a very effective
campaigning contrast speech between what
the world that America will look like
between the two by the way there's a
video out there on MSNBC 403 p.m.
Central Time
Tulsa time a literally an entrance for
Trump supporters blocked by black lives
matter protesters it's right there they
reported on it on the Democrats favorite
channel MSNBC but to the to the content
of the speech the president talked about
the left and their attempts to erase
history here's a part of what he had to
say and we'll get you to react the
unhinge left-wing mob is trying to
vandalize our history tear down our
statues and punish canceled and
persecute anyone who does not conform to
their demands for absolute and total
control we're not conforming that's why
we're here excellent this cruel campaign
of censorship and exclusion violates
everything we hold dear is America's why
does this resonate with people so much
because this is a crowd that doesn't
want to see our country torn down they
don't wanna see our country burnt down
they're tired of watching all the
looting that's been going on they want
to see our country lift it up they want
they want to unite with fellow Americans
the tolerance was inside of that room
you saw a lot of people holding I mean
we're just saying right next to the a
section of blacks for Trump and you saw
veterans in the crowd and and all sorts
of other minorities and different
viewpoints it you had an inclusive arena
filled with people who want to
unite for a better country and you put
on the TV and you're watching
individuals trying to tear down our
country in so many different ways so
that contrast is it's crystal clear the
president is is right to highlight it we
would like to put up you know more
reflections on you know whether it's a
founding father of our our country you
or or others who served in the military
you know we want to celebrate America we
want to celebrate our Constitution our
freedoms our liberties we want to defend
them and protect them and meanwhile
we're watching people just looking to
try to tear it all down and it's it's a
sad contrast but it's an effective one
to to point out congressman I want to
ask you quickly about New York because
it's a big day for New York City
tomorrow New York's gonna enter phase
two of reopening allowing shopping
outdoor dining what do you make of that
your your district on Long Island is
moving toward Phase three so how's this
gonna go how do you anticipate that this
is gonna play out yeah so parts of
upstate ori moved into Phase three as
you point out Long Island's moving to
phase three this upcoming Wednesday is
expected to New York City moving into
Phase two the economy needs to get
reopened the numbers have been very low
for over the course of last few weeks on
so many different levels of what was
being followed and what was crazy is
what is before you saw New York City
moving into phase one of the economy
reopening you had tens of thousands of
people moving into Phase eleven of
rioting and looting not just protesting
but what they took their took their
activities to a next level that got a
whole lot of people hurt I would point
out you know while you're watching maybe
25,000 people who will gather together
for a protest say in Brooklyn
you're capping high school high school
graduations at 150 that doesn't make
sense you're capping houses of worship
at 25% that doesn't make sense you're
not allowing some kids to go play around
in the local park where your Jewish kids
like to go play maybe just a few blocks
from where that protest was going on so
I would I would actually encourage the
governor to look at where the
inconsistency is across the board and
that will lead to resentments getting
warm people are tired of of
being cooped up they want to get out
there and enjoy their lives so you know
it's time to reopen but we can actually
be reopening faster and we could do it
safely phase 11 didn't know it was there
but saw it before my eyes that's exactly
right
Carson Lee's album thank you so much for
your time this morning appreciate it
thank you